[Applause]
all right and we have tom bower
hi tom
hi
hi y'all hi family
so it's going to be a dare are you ready
for this
yes drew i would like you to put red
lipstick on rossi ross
oh
you're going to bring out my natural
beauty huh
it'll go your shirt pockets
like how do i do it like this or like
stretch out here this way okay because i
no you know okay
yeah that's better oh that's it thank
you okay you need lighting okay just
don't move uh uh-huh
do i want to do it this way and then
we'll do a reveal okay and then tilt
your head down okay okay perfect okay
you know it's so hard not to talk you're
moving
how long it is
do you want me to get it right i do i do
i do
okay good perfect yes okay are you ready
yes okay count me in tell me andrew one
two
three
i just saw myself i just saw myself
[Applause]
what you're witnessing is the birth of
my new signature look hello
fabulous i like it i think you look
really pretty
yeah okay i look yeah you did a good job
you did a good job
you did do a good job thank you
tom
um what gave you the idea to do this so
my daughter and i love makeup aurora
she's 14. of course she's into makeup
right now so
well could i put a little basket of
flower beauty together for you guys i
would love that
okay that's done i'll get it to you
after the show well thank you everybody
for choosing to spend your time with us
we make a show for you
[Applause]
[Music]
you